foreign
I first want to talk to you about the
millionaire minimalist this blew my mind
did you know that Chad Ochocinco is a
millionaire yes you probably knew that
but did you know that he is also a
minimalist roll the video wow
I'm gonna make enough money I can fly my
private I ain't playing private Spirit
put me on Spirit exit row Window Seat
that's all I need long as I get from
point A to point B I don't need private
athletes more so if you can get to a
point in your career where your name
becomes bigger than anything you can
purchase there's your value wow my name
itself Ocho Cinco at one point even
still to this day is bigger than why am
I driving a Ferrari why am I driving a
Rolls-Royce and I'm Ocho
oh we talk about jewelry and watches and
chains never brought real anything when
I was playing never what was the point I
went to Claire's so awesome yes for what
what am I doing it for the women don't
deal with you anyway because of who you
are right and then the other women who
really doing their homework don't Google
how much you're making already right why
am I buying a 50 000 watch 80 000 watch
what time is it real quick please it's
uh 20 minutes before how much that cost
me
time is free so what I'm paying for far
right what I'm Ocho what's the point
right there's nothing I can buy that's
bigger than my name alone so it made no
sense
but everybody's caught up an image and
looking a certain way and being rich
it's me
it's pointless you know how hard it is
to live like that all the time
consistently and be fly every day
jewelry and listen areas of rappers
think about the era before before us
right everybody was flashy stunned and
stunning and after 10 years what happens
you can't it's impossible to sustain
it's impossible people's social media
well if I spin this bag I'm gonna just
go make it back
like you think you know people they
think the Cure and the prop the fix for
the problem is will give me more money
I'm gonna be all right but the more you
make the more you spend right if you
have no discipline and no structure yes
absolutely every time yes
dude that's great first off I'm a huge
Bengals fan so I saw who Chad Ochocinco
is so he's like uh he's just one of the
best wide receivers that they had
um yeah and I'll just leave it at that
he was yeah he was a good player it's
funny though I love what I just saw
there because he went from you know I'm
oh Joe mother Ethan Cinco like flashy
doing all the crazy things so like it
apparently had this Awakening of like
why am I doing this and um I think my
favorite part of that video was watching
Shannon sharp basically kind of get
disappointed at first but then slowly
like you started to see him like his
head like oh yeah I see what you're
saying the only thing that I disagreed
with in the video itself is he's like my
name is bigger than the logo totally
agree with that sure but that applies to
everyone
who you are is bigger than any logo that
you can wear I don't care if your name
is Jane or John or Jeff or Susan it is
bigger and better than the Lexus than
the Prada bag it's better than the giant
house than the Rolex because as he
Illustrated here that Rolex is not going
to buy you more time your time is free
why are you spending fifty thousand
dollars on it yeah and I I think he
would agree with you
but I think the only way his statement
has power is if he keeps it about
himself the moment he names any other
name and makes it about you then it
sounds like he's being condemning it
sounds like he's being privileged and
insensitive and unempathetic so he's got
to keep it about him right because he
knows that ultimately his name is the
product of what he invested in his name
is what he made of his name right he
chose to take pride in his potential he
chose to develop his abilities to
dedicate himself to Excellence in his
craft and he built the name that makes
him say what the value of what I do the
value of how I show up and my attitude
and my craftsmanship is more powerful
than any validation that some other
company's name can give to me and I
think the wink and Nod is hey I'm
sharing this for a reason I'm sharing
this because I want this opinion to get
out there I'm hoping that I can
influence and Inspire somebody else to
rethink the message that they're getting
from consumer culture but he's got to
keep it personal in order for it to have
impact because the moment you take your
story and turn it into a sermon people
start to get defensive yeah so wisdom
says I'm gonna tell my story and I'm
gonna let who's ready to pick it up pick
it up man I I cannot believe the change
that he's made so he was Chad Johnson
and his number was 85 and
um he was one of the flashiest he was
like a Terrell Owens just like super
flashy um he did this like celebration
he literally hit a cell phone
underneath of the padding on the goal
post and you gotta he got a touchdown he
must have hit him on either end I don't
know but he reaches underneath the
padding pulls out his cell phone gets
fine like fifty thousand dollars for
like pretending that he's calling his
mom to tell her about the touchdown or
whatever but he was he was so flashy
that he literally changed his name to
his his jersey number Chad Ochocinco
right yeah so the last thing that I'll
say about this video is
it makes you realize
that if he doesn't need it he doesn't
need the private jet he doesn't need the
flashy jewelry he doesn't need the logo
on a bag or on a piece of clothing he
can afford all of these things
but he doesn't have the need for it and
because he doesn't need it he's not
controlled by those things he won't
apply private he'll fly spirit I won't
even fly spirit
that's insane but you know what it's
crazy he's Freer than I am then yeah and
that is the point Bravo Chad yeah
absolutely that's awesome did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free